may recall a couple of years ago when
the estate of Theodore Geisel who's
better known as Dr Seuss of course made
the decision to stop selling a number of
Seuss's books because the books featured
culturally insensitive words and themes
one of the books for example contained a
shocking reference to Eskimos and we're
not allowed to call Eskimos Eskimos
anymore for reasons that have never
fully been explained but it's too late
to explain these things to Dr Seuss
himself as he died 30 years ago all they
can do is posthumously label his work
bigoted and shove a chunk of his catalog
into the memory hole which is exactly
what they did now many people the
optimistic ones anyway thought that
maybe the whole Seuss Saga represented
cancel culture at its most absurd and at
the very least they figured it's the
most ludicrous example of censoring a
dead children's author that we'll ever
see can't get worse than that but they
forget in spite of my many reminders
that progressivism is Progressive like
cancer it grows and spreads and doesn't
stop can't stop until its host is dead
and so this past weekend another beloved
children's author who died a year before
Dr Seuss found himself in the woke Cults
crosshairs in this incident actually
makes the soos cancellation look
downright reasonable by comparison
so the guardian reports on the efforts
by rolled Dahl's publisher to actually
rewrite his books in order to bring them
into line with modern sensibilities
reading from the report it says rolled
dolls children's books are being
Rewritten to remove language deemed
offensive by the publisher Puffin Puffin
has hired sensitivity readers to rewrite
chunks of the author's text to make sure
the book's quote can continue to be
enjoyed by all today resulting in
extensive changes across Dahl's Works
hundreds of changes were made to the
original text and some passages not
written by doll have been added but the
Roald Dahl story company said quote It's
Not Unusual to review the language
during a new print run and any changes
were small and carefully considered
now if you thought that the uh you know
Dei Consultants were useless parasites
what can we say about professional
sensitivity readers I suppose we would
say much the same about them but perhaps
maybe we might give them we might be
tempted to give them a little bit of
credit for finding such a profitable uh
yet low effort grift and speaking of low
effort here are some of the changes that
were made at their best
quote edits have been made to
descriptions of characters physical
appearances the word fat has been cut
from every new edition of relevant books
while the word ugly has also been called
The Daily Telegraph reported Augustus
Gloop and Charlie and the Chocolate
Factory is now described as enormous in
the twits Mrs twit is no longer ugly and
beastly but just beastly
well that's good because now the line
has left open the possibility that Mrs
twit might be beastly yet not ugly
perhaps she is a big beastly beautiful
woman that might be a somewhat
incoherent image I can't imagine what a
beastly yet attractive person would look
like but at least you get the
alliteration there big beastly beautiful
reading more it says in the witches a
paragraph explaining that witches are
bald beneath their wigs ends with this
new line quote there are plenty of other
reasons why women might wear wigs and
there is certainly nothing wrong with
that
I'm surprised that they didn't add yet
another line to to note also that uh not
all witches are supernatural creatures
who create magical potions to turn
children into mice as they do in doll's
book you know there are other kinds of
witches as well in fact we even have
witches in Congress quite a few of them
one of them used to be Speaker of the
House it seems the sensitivity readers
missed an opportunity to fully combat
the stigma against witches I'm a little
disappointed by that hopefully they'll
catch it on the next go around back to
the guardian says in previous editions
of James and the Giant Peach the
centipede sings on Sponge was
terrifically fat and tremendously flabby
at that and on Spiker was thin as a wire
and dry as a bone only dryer both verses
have been removed and in their places
are the Rhymes Aunt sponge was a nasty
old brute and deserved to be squashed by
the fruit and Aunt Spiker was much of
the same and deserves half of the blame
this is another important edit as we all
know it's deeply offensive to call a
woman fat we should instead be polite
and merely call them brutes who deserve
to be squished to death
but you know we shouldn't be surprised
that these changes make no sense at all
after all the woke police they still
haven't quite figured out what to do
with fatness because on the one hand of
course they want to stop you from
calling people fat because it's
intolerant but on the other hand they
preach about fat acceptance and declare
that fat is beautiful but if fat is
acceptable and beautiful
then why can't we call people fat
shouldn't we would we be complimenting
them in that case I mean one of the
greatest things you could say to someone
is hey you fat ass is he calling them
beautiful
so the sensitivity readers are a bit
confused on that point but one thing
they know for sure is that any reference
to biological sex is of course terribly
offensive now reading again it says
references to female characters have
disappeared Miss Trunchbull and Matilda
one say most formidable female is now a
most formidable woman gender-neutral
terms have been added in places where
Charlie and the chocolate factories
Oompa Loompas were small men they are
now small people the cloud men in James
the giant peach have become Cloud people
Puffin and the Roald Dahl story company
made the changes in conjunction with
inclusive Minds which its spokesperson
describes as quote a collective for
people who are passionate about
inclusion and accessibility in
children's literature Alexandra strick a
co-founder of inclusive Minds says that
they aim to ensure authentic
representation by working closely with
the book world and with those who have
lived experience of any facet of
diversity
a notice from the publisher sits at the
bottom of the copyright page of the
latest editions of doll's books and says
quote
the wonderful words of Roald Dahl can
transport you to different worlds and
introduce you to the most marvelous
characters this book book was written
many years ago and so we regularly
reviewed the language to ensure that it
continued continued to be enjoyed by all
today
now as I said at the beginning this is
all significantly worse than simply
Banning books or taking them off the
shelves it represents a rather startling
escalation by the woke Brigade
because if they had you know removed the
offensive quote-unquote doll books from
circulation that would be a ridiculous
and shameful move just like it was with
Dr Seuss but it would at least be honest
I mean more honest at any rate and it
would keep the author's work intact
but now they've they've taken the litter
Liberty to rewrite the books and change
the author's words without his consent
to make it more acceptable by their
standards
and you don't need to strain very hard
to see where this is going I mean it's
one thing to imagine a world where
Shakespeare has been entirely removed
from the classroom because it was a
white male who authored works that
contain problematic themes that Prospect
is disturbing enough if it isn't already
happening which it probably is
but now imagine a world where kids are
taught Shakespeare except they're
reading things that Shakespeare never
actually wrote
I mean I would rather Shakespeare be
cast aside as a toxic white male than
retroactively edited to be turned into a
woke transgendered polysexual or
whatever they would do to it yet that's
where we're headed
now the problem with this approach is
not simply that it's politically correct
we have we have moved way past mere
political correctness at this point the
problem is that first of all it's a lie
so you may wish that an author had
written something a different way and
used different language uh gone this
direction instead of that but those
wishes are born from the fact that the
work is not your work it came from
someone else's mind
you wish he had written it a certain way
but he didn't write it that way he wrote
what he wrote no matter how you feel
about it
this is no different from rewriting the
history books to tell the story of what
of what you think should have happened
in history rather than telling what
actually did happen
and of course that's exactly what
they're going to do with the history
books if they aren't already
the left believes that it has the moral
authority to alter anything it wants to
alter
because it doesn't believe that anything
that conflicts with their worldview has
any right to exist in the first place
and that's really what this comes down
to
from their perspective Roald Dahl had no
right to to author those kinds of books
in the first place
because it conflicts with with them and
it makes them feel bad and so he had no
right to do that and so that gives them
the moral license to do whatever they
want if that means burning the books
Banning them they can do that if that
means rewriting it it means that
this is not only unethical and arrogant
in the extreme editing a dead writer's
word so they sound better to you
but it also deprives Children of the
full enrichment and edification that can
come from from reading the Vivid and
even maybe sometimes a little upsetting
If the child is an especially sensitive
type uh words of a great imaginative
writer
see we tend to worry that this kind of
censorship will help to indoctrinate
children into wokeness and we're right
to worry about that we should be worried
about it
but it's perhaps an even greater concern
that it will help to make our children
into Bland boring people
which of course is an inevitable
consequence of making them woke
and if you want to make children Bland
and boring and bored
there is no better way to do it than to
reimagine Great children's literature so
that it sounds like something written by
A diversity consultant
that is just about the worst and most
disrespectful thing you can do to a
piece of literature and it's also a very
terrible thing to do to the child who is
reading it I'll move over to the members
block if you're not a member yet become
a member and use code wall should check
out for two months free on all annual
plans hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]